The opposite of cay plus 1 is less than or equal to sara is cay plus 1 is
greater than sara. The opposite of cay plus 1 is greater than or equal to sara
is cay plus 1 is less than sara. And the opposite of cay plus 1 is not equal to
sara is cay plus one equals equals to sara. You may have thought that the
opposite cay plus 1 is less than or equals to sara should be cay plus 1 is
greater than or equals to sara. But the opposite value has to disagree every
possible value of cay and sara. Let's look at a representative set of
example's. Our original expression was cay plus 1 is less than or equals to
sara. We found that when Cay has 3 Twitter followers and Sara has 4 Twitter
followers, that's the boundary. So, I'm using that case and two cases, one on
each side of that boundary to compare these three conditions to see which ones
are opposites. When cay has 3 and sara has 3, it's not true that cay plus one
is less than or equal to sara. When cay has 3, and I have 4, this condition's
true. When cay has 3 and I have 5, the condition is still true. Now for the
next condition, we find that they disagree on conditions that are not right on
the boundary. But, right on the boundary, they agree. So these conditions are
not opposites. But this last condition is true for the first case, false for
the boundary case and false for the last case. So, it differs in every case
from the original condition. You could write out similar tables for the other
two original equations, but I think this is enough writing tables for now.